uh judd i'm going to start with you i
have an individual question for you um
i'm always so you've made a number of
movies of all the films you've made
which is the one that changed the most
in the editing room and why that's a
very good question
well
of the ones i've directed
i mean i'm pretty close to my
structure and then i just you know i'm
in a war with myself about how long to
make it because i have a long attention
span when i like something
you know so now like the whole world is
willing to watch like five episodes of
narcos at a time i'm like yes now you're
getting to what i want to do
but but they're they're all kind of
similar i mean there's never been one
where like i've reinvented it in the
edits like it's usually what i thought
it was in the beginning so there's like
nothing dramatic no no huge changes no
i've never done a reshoot on any of my
movies either and it's not that they
didn't need them i always just figure
that the second i'm done shooting like
in my head that world is gone
all i have is the footage like it's a
documentary i never think i'm gonna go
back in there and clean up that scene
like the second we stop shooting i
mentally
can't like get back in it again uh i
heard you're friends with colin and i'm
just curious what was it like telling
him that you wanted to make this movie
was it an awkward conversation or was he
like oh you should you should do this i
mean i called colin while i was writing
the movie and then we have friends on
white lotus
and you know we were checking in with
everybody who was in the middle of a
bubble production and everybody was
really great and you know they would
tell a story it's like oh someone put on
a wig and escaped the hotel tonight and
and so we would just you know put things
in the movie but he was really great i
went i went with him to uh watch them
score
the the new jurassic movie and it was
one of the great great experiences at
abbey road so he's been a great friend
to the project watching this movie you
it shines a light on the fact that
sometimes people are doing press that
don't like each other and you put on a
brave face and you you know smile and
get along so of the three of you who
hates who i hate both of them so much no
yeah it was difficult
very difficult to work with
so many
ice coffees
and thrown at my trailer yeah
every morning
yeah
no it was it was it was brilliant man
like it was one we were all so excited
to be allowed back outside so that was
like yeah we just so desperate to have
human interaction yeah it's like that
new story yeah oh my god a new story
that happened this year
so yeah it was really fun one of the
other things about this movie or and
also just in general i'm constantly
amazed at the level of like when certain
press ask like actors or a director to
like solve a world problem you know like
in a junket situation like this so i am
very curious what have you been asked
that you're like are you effin kidding
me you're asking me this right now yeah
luckily no one is asking us anything
important
yeah yeah yeah no one expects us to know
anything but do you know what i mean
though oh yeah absolutely but but i
think i've proven over a long period of
time that i'm the wrong person to ask
for advice on almost anything
if net at some point netflix could make
a cliff beast's movie and i'm just
curious in the contracts that you guys
signed did you work in four
residuals for residuals
yes where they get rid of me but keep
the cliff beast thing going yes like
jaws 3d
without spielberg
it could happen i have to check with my
lawyers now
did you actually think about that at all
that that could actually become
something we we laughed about the whole
movie we said the logical next thing is
that we make cliffs yeah and then when
the fake trailer before it came out i
was like this is about this i'd watch
this
yeah there was a surprising amount of
dancing in this movie i mean like a real
surprising amount and i'm curious is it
more nerve-wracking trying to coordinate
dancing and all that stuff than it is
for like a more dramatic scene because
dancing you almost like get judged more
on that when you have dancers like this
yeah so i trained at the royal ballet
for many many many years
but um it was it was i think i think
what was maybe the most difficult
because when the actual dance
came about i think we were all so like
excited to do it it was kind of like
trying to treat a room of toddlers to
like focus on what was happening yeah
and we're all just going like
yeah i was taught by james brown so i
went in there and just smashed it and i
had many breaks they were like can we
just give us a chance to teach everyone
else so yeah go on the novices and then
no i'm joking but everyone was really
good
everyone took it very seriously
yeah yeah i was our dance arts teacher
was on us like i was really bad with
choreography like actually doing it at
the same time so i'd be like oh sharla
can i watch and then copy and she's like
okay and then i'd watch see them do it
then i'll turn it on all right there it
is and i still miss it
for me to do work
it was funny because
ryan heppington
choreographed all of our dances and then
he choreographed the big finale of
euphoria
that mod was in so he
had a lot of collaboration with him so
that was fun because we had the greatest
choreographer you ever could have
doing our ridiculous dances well i've
actually this has been a really good
year also because i love the peacemaker
opening the james guns show yeah as a
great dance thing this has great dance
euphoria it's just it's a um is it is it
the pandemic or just everyone is into
doing dance stuff
who's done
that's wicked though i love seeing dance
stuff
right there's also like i found it very
like satisfying to learn like it was
like a new skill that then immediately
left as soon as i started yeah yeah if i
tried to do it now it would be the
saddest thing i ever caught on tape
i'm very curious i'm obviously also a
fan of pam and she wrote the script with
you can you sort of talk about working
with her and um just the collaboration
because she's also a very gifted writer
well you know i had this idea
and i was walking on the beach all
summer long and i i kept thinking about
the the stress of trying to make movies
in the bubble because there's this
pressure you know from the whole system
to keep making movies even during a
difficult time
and i realized i would never write it
quickly enough unless i was really
laughing and enjoying myself and pam
brady is the funniest and you know she
co-wrote the south park movie and and
she did a lady dynamite with maria
bamford and we did just laugh so hard
while doing it and she she also just put
me in a good mood because she's like a
happy person like i'm more of a more
merose comedy writer like is this joe
good do you like this joke and she's a
laugher and she's the reason why we're
able to make it and she was in america
when we were doing the movie we were in
london so i would call her on my way
home from work every night when she was
waking up and we would rewrite the next
day's work and this leads me to my next
thing which is uh on set how controlling
pretend you're not here how controlling
is your director on set and how much is
he allowing you to sort of you know find
stuff in the moment
oh he it was very you were very very
encouraging it was like such a lovely
environment in that you would kind of
follow the script at first and then you
had judd was on this like her speaker
system
and then
kind of really trust you to kind of like
riff and improvise as well as there's
like the writers also like offering up
suggestions and stuff like that so it
felt
incredibly collaborative which just i
think also created a lovely dynamic on
set it kind of felt like everyone was
contributing to this i have a question
how much does judd pay you to say this
so much and am i an eyewatering amount
and it's worth it well this is harry's
first movie
and
you know we didn't even know how much he
would be in the movie we just said we
need a coveted supervisor harry is
really funny we'll just have him around
in all the scenes and maybe we can throw
him something to do and the first day he
did this incredible riff with guzz and
then we were like did he prepare those
improvs yeah so the next day he had a
scene and we threw him
a curve ball where we were doing nothing
in the script and it was all just as
good and we were like oh you realize
that was a fun little test yeah
oh my god like the entire first two days
it was like oh my god i thought i was
gonna faint the entire time it was we
were all like we were all i remember
that my first day i think i had a scene
review yeah yeah
and i remember we we
hadn't met judd in person and as soon as
we got in ben was like all right can we
all just stand on our marks and yeah and
then next week we hear the voices of god
going all right guys we're going to do
yeah so we're like oh gosh we're in it
we're in there yeah all right okay all
we need to do is get past this moment
and we won't lose our jumps so we all
did we were just
looking at each other the entire time
was it funny was it funny good and then
once that bit once we got through that
and it was a laugh and then it just
became much more relaxing and we started
to become more free i always felt like
the day that um i felt the most free was
with me and karen you know we were doing
the why i do birds that was a really
nice that was crazy everyone was
together and everyone was just you know
that was a fun day yeah it's really
really laid back really chill much fun
on that note i need to stop i'm just
gonna say again i really appreciate you
guys making me laugh and good luck with
the rest of your speed dating